In the last module, we took
first steps towards understanding
the electrical properties
of individual neurons.
We learned how electrical
forces and diffusion give rise
to membrane potentials,
and we learned how cells can generate
and propagate signals called action
potentials, or 'spikes',
along the membrane.
Understanding the properties of
the neuronal membrane is essential,
but understanding just these properties
isn't sufficient to give us insight
into collective behavior of the billions
of connected neurons in our brains.
Luckily for us, we can approach
neuroscience at many different scales
and levels of analysis, and we don't
have to confront the full complexity
of everything all at once.
That's what we'll be exploring
throughout the rest of this course
as we slowly go from our understanding
of single molecules such as ion
channels'
...to the electrical behavior of neurons
...to their collective
behavior in small circuits
...and finally onto how they become
organized in large functional regions
of the brain.
Let's start simple, though.
Since we've examined one neuron, a
logical next question is how do two
neurons connect with one another?
We'll first examine some basic
cellular anatomy of neurons.
So far, we haven't made too much of
the fact that the majority of neurons
are 'polarized'
cells.
That is, they have one
portion of the cell
for receiving inputs and another
portion for sending outputs.
The parts of the cells that are
specialized for receiving inputs from
other cells are called 'dendrites.'
The word 'dendrite' comes from the
Greek word 'dendron', meaning tree,
and as you can see the dendrites
have a branching, tree-like shape.
A signal received by a dendrite
is passed to the cell body.
If there is a sufficient depolarization
of the cell body membrane
to initiate an action potential, then an
action potential is sent down the axon.
The axon then carries the propagating
action potential to another neuron.
So what actually happens at the
boundary between two neurons,
between the axon of one neuron
and the dendrite of another?
This interface is
called a 'synapse',
and it'll be the focus of this lesson.
There are two general types of synapses
that we'll cover in depth later:
electrical synapses,
and chemical synapses.
Electrical synapses are less
common in our own nervous systems,
but they're simpler to think
about, so let's start with them.
Electrical synapses are
basically pores between two cell
that allow ions to pass through.
They allow the passage
of that electrical signal
through to a neighboring
cell without much fuss.
It's not so different than just
combining two cells into one larger
cell.
There are lots of reasons that nature
might need synapses like this from time
to time -- they're fast, and they
allow cells to couple together with
a high degree of synchronicity.
But most neurons are connected together
by a much more complicated structure
called a chemical synapse.
In a chemical synapse, rather than
simply passing along an electrical
signal from one cell to another, the
action potential travels to the end
of the axon and causes a chemical to
be released into a very small space
between the two neurons called
the 'synaptic cleft'.
This chemical is taken up
by the downstream neuron,
on the other side of the cleft.
This chemical signal can
cause the downstream neuron
to depolarize its membrane,
converting the chemical signal back
into an electrical one, or it can
have other effects on the cell.
This chemical step is
slower than transmission
across an electrical
synapse, but it opens up
an enormously diverse repertoire
of different and more complex
kinds of signaling,
and synaptic function
plays a critical role in
computations performed by neurons.
We'll spend the the rest of this
unit exploring the inner workings
of chemical synapses, on our way to
beginning to look at how networks
of interconnected neurons
give rise to behavior.
We'll also look at the role
of defective synaptic physiology
in neurological and
psychiatric disorders,
and we'll see how synapses can be
targeted by various psychoactive drugs
and poisons.
Finally we'll wrap up by looking
at how synapse can change with time,
in response to external stimuli, playing
a foundational role in how we learn
and remember.